most expensive thing I'm wearing
um my ego
um yeah Saint Lauren amazing the best
would you mind if Mike makes me look
extra big probably
that
means the most this was my father's but
it's a Titan and I don't know that
people wear them anymore and so this
means a whole lot to me and I'm happy to
have him here with me
I'll never tell because I don't know
um you know my my favorite thing I'm
wearing right now what might be this
suit also this uh this weird little
thing that I got at a consignment shop
in uh in Charleston I don't know it
would be this luxurious chain it's Dion
by Dion if you know what I mean so the
favorite thing of my underwear
all right
easy